kein urlaub ohne aktuellen corona test
der bunt und fast alle länder einigen
sich auf einen beherbergungs verbot für
gäste aus deutschen corona hotspots
prozessauftakt mit politischer
sprengkraft die bundesanwaltschaft sagte
russland habe einen mord mitten in
berlin in auftrag gegeben
und razzia beim deutschen fußball-bund
der verband soll bei einnahmen aus
bandenwerbung jahrelang steuern
hinterzogen an
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem mittwoch an meiner seite ist für
den sport wieder norbert lehmann als
wunder von mir es ist nicht nur berlin
in einigen deutschen großstädten steigen
die korona neuinfektionen sprunghaft an
die bundesregierung warnt davor dass die
gesundheitsämter bald nicht mehr in der
lage sind die infektionsketten
nachzuverfolgen
bundesweit soll jetzt ein beherbergungs
verbot gelten für reisen der aus den
inländischen hotspots die keinen negativ
test vorweisen können
aktuell sehen die zahlen so aus im
schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 2380 menschen
infiziert 90 mehr als gestern
ein blick auf die vergangenen monate
zeigt nach dem höhepunkt anfang april
mit durchschnittlich fast 6000 neu
infizierten täglich viel die kurve im
sommer steil ab und steigt jetzt wieder
an
an seinem stern berichtet hauptstadt und
hotspot berlin kämpft gegen schlechte
virus zahlen die einwohner mit problemen
etwa wenn sie reisen wollen innerhalb
von deutschland grundsätzlich vereinbart
heute ein bundesweites beherbergungs
verbot für menschen die aus einem
risikogebiet kommen also aus einer
region in der es mehr als 50 neue
infektionen gab pro 100000 einwohner in
einer woche um dann trotzdem ein
hotelzimmer zu bekommen braucht man
künftig einen frischen negativen corona
test ich freue mich dass wir eine
einheitliche regelung für deutschland
haben sie soll sicherheit schaffen
sicherheit für die gäste in den
urlaubsgebieten zur ferienzeit aber auch
für die betreffenden menschen aus den
risikogebieten sagt markus söder
doch ob das beherbergungs verbot
tatsächlich überall und gleich
konsequent umgesetzt wird ist noch offen
es gibt widerstand aus einigen
landesregierungen geeint sind die in der
sorge vor mehr corona fällen ein grund
wachsende sorglosigkeit viele beim
feiern das ist ein problem vor allem in
den großen städten der republik
wir sind in einer weltweiten krise und
das glück kann nicht darin liegen sich
nachts um drei auf öffentlicher straße
besuchen zu können
die pandemie wird in den metropolen
entschieden wo wenig platz ist so viele
menschen auf kleiner fläche miteinander
leben
dort müssen wir die pandemie in den
griff bekommen im griff ist die lage
aktuell in den so wichtigen
krankenhäusern fast 8500 intensivbetten
sind statt heute insgesamt frei auf den
intensivstationen liegen weniger als 500
kubik 19 patienten
die lage ist so dass sie noch
kontrollierbar ist also die
gesundheitsämter kommen noch mit der
verfolgung hinterher infektionsketten
können unterbrochen werden allerdings
sollten die zahlen natürlich jetzt nicht
viel weiter steigen weil das natürlich
auch die gefahr in sich birgt dass sich
auch ältere mitbürger eben infizieren
können
es bleibt also kompliziert und schwierig
in diesem pandemie herbst in deutschland
und welche chor ohne regeln in den
einzelnen bundesländern gelten können
sie in der zdf- heute- app nachlesen da
waren sie zum beispiel was sie bei
reisen beachten müssen und wo überall
die masken pflicht gilt zu einem fall
höchster politischer brisanz steckt die
russische regierung hinter dem so
genannten tiergarten mount vor gut einem
jahr deutschlands bundesanwaltschaft ist
davon überzeugt klären soll das von
heute an das berliner kammergericht auf
der anklagebank ein mann aus russland
das opfer ein georgier tschetschenische
abstammung er galt in russland offiziell
als terrorist auch dieser fall belastet
das deutsch russische verhältnis schwer
felix zimmermann
august 2009 10 im kleinen tiergarten in
berlin wird ein mann von einem fahrrad
aus angeschossen und anschließend mit
zwei kopfschüssen hingerichtet der
mutmaßliche täter ein russe wird schnell
gefasst
heute prozessbeginn vor dem berliner
kammergericht kein gewöhnlicher
mordprozess sondern unsichtbar sitzt
russland mit auf der anklagebank
es handelt sich nach unseren
erkenntnissen um einen auftragsmord
staatliche russische stellen aus sicht
der russischen regierung war das tat
opfer ein staatsfeind insbesondere
deshalb weil der getötete im
tschetschenien krieg gegen russland
gekämpft hatte
das opfer war georgier kämpfte als
kommandeur tschetschenischer milizen von
russland wurde er als terrorist gesucht
und die dürfen nach russischem recht
neutralisiert werden
zwei mordanschläge hat er überlebt den
dritten nicht
sollte es das gericht als erwiesen
ansehen dass russland ein
exekutionskommando nach berlin sandte
wäre dies nicht nur anstiftung zum mord
sondern eine völkerrechtswidrige
missachtung deutscher hoheitsrechte und
des rechtsstaatsprinzips im prozess geht
es daher nicht nur um die aufklärung
eines mordes sondern um die frage ob und
wie russland die innere sicherheit in
deutschland gefährdet 2009/10 gabler die
mir putin einen kommentar zu dem
tiergarten getöteten georgier ab - wo
dieser mann wurde von uns gesucht er ist
ein bandit ein brutaler und
blutrünstiger mensch viele deuten die
aussage als schuldeingeständnis doch der
kreml weist jede verantwortung für die
tötung von sich der angeklagte selbst
gab heute keine erklärung zur sache ab
der tiergarten mordprozess sein ausgang
könnte für das deutsch russische
verhältnis gravierende folgen haben
ja aber das deutsch russische verhältnis
ist ja schon denkbar schlecht stark
unter der manager ja genau das kann man
eigentlich gar nicht anders sagen es gab
in den vergangenen jahren einfach zu
viele vorfälle die deren spuren dann
auch nach russland gezeigt haben und das
nicht nur in deutschland es gab einen
hacker angriff auf den bundestag 2015 es
gab den giftanschlag auf sergej skripal
in großbritannien und jetzt gerade
jüngst erst den anschlag auf alexej
nawalny auch wieder ein giftanschlag bei
dem jetzt die bundesregierung vermutet
dass auch staatliche russische stellen
involviert sein könnten und das ist eben
eine lange reihe von vorfällen zu denen
sich auch die europäische union schon
geäußert hat und auch in der
vergangenheit schon besorgt geäußert hat
weil sie da eine gewisse kontinuität
sieht aber deutschland und die eu haben
bisher immer mit größeren maßnahmen
gezögert da scheint sich jetzt
allerdings etwas zu tun
heute gab es von aus der eu die
nachricht dass sanktionen gegen zwei
einzelpersonen beschlossen wurden wegen
des bundestags hacks und ebenfalls heute
wurde angekündigt dass deutschland und
frankreich sich gemeinsam für neue
sanktionen gegen russland einsetzen
wollen wegen des falls navalny am montag
soll das in brüssel mit den eu
außenministern gesprochen werden die
frage ist allerdings wie groß werden
diese sanktionen dann ausfallen bleibt
es wieder bei sanktionen gegen
einzelpersonen wenn ja trifft es dann
auch mal hochrangige personen in
russland vielleicht auch aus dem umfeld
von wladimir putin
das ist alles noch offen aber man sieht
deutschland und die eu sind jetzt
gewählt diplomatische stopp schilder
aufzustellen
danke für diese einschätzung chacon
salah badi aus berlin noch eine
personalie aus der hauptstadt martina
rosenberg soll präsidentin des
militärischen abschirmdienstes werden
und damit die erste frau in diesem amt
die juristin ist am
bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig für
disziplinarverfahren wer soldaten
zuständig als mhd chefin soll sie den
rechtsextremismus in den reihen des
geheimdienstes entschieden bekämpfen
zur wirecard ag erst zumindest auf dem
papier milliarden umsätze und
hoffnungsträger im dax dann der fall ins
bodenlose und mit jan marsalek ein
vorstandsmitglied auf der flucht ob und
wie die finanzaufsicht und auch die
politik versagt haben wehrt ab morgen
ein untersuchungsausschuss des
bundestags die regierung präsentierte
heute wie sie künftig skandale wie
wirecard verhindern will
nicole diekmann es geht um sehr viel
geld in wirecard skandal und um
bilanzfälschung welche rolle dabei etwa
die finanzaufsichtsbehörde bafin
gespielt hat darum sollte es heute in
berlin nicht gehen
verantwortlich für die bafin ist das
ministerium von olaf scholz dem
finanzminister und spd kanzlerkandidaten
ging es vor allem darum tatkraft zu
demonstrieren
wirecard ist das ergebnis kriminellen
handelns aber das darf uns nicht davon
abhalten
deshalb trotzdem alle die
institutionellen vorkehrungen zu
schaffen ich zu schaffen die man braucht
um nach möglichkeit solche grünen
handlung so früh wie möglich aufzudecken
kommen sollen neue gesetz nun also erst
mal ein aktionsplan darin vorschläge wie
die verschärfung der zivilrechtlichen
haftung von abschlussprüfern der aufbau
einer schnellen eingreiftruppe bei der
bafin und die stärkere nutzung von
hinweisen von whistleblower weil das
soll geprüft werden
ich hab nicht gezählt wie oft auch drin
stand ob das häufigste wort ward prüfen
dafür haben wir den aktionsplan von
einem schuss nicht gebraucht für den
skandal beim zahlungsdienstleister
wirecard macht stolz vor allem externe
prüfer verantwortlich sie sollen künftig
maximal zehn jahre für ein unternehmen
zuständig sein dürfen
die opposition aber zeigt auch auf die
regierung stichwort lobbyismus
vielleicht kommt man ins kanzleramt wenn
man im kanzleramt es war ein protokoll
keine mitschnitte war mein guter freund
kabinettskollege war
inwieweit haben diese gäste und freunde
dann einfluss laut olaf scholz sind die
gesetzesentwürfe fast fertig dass er
seinen aktionsplan nun ausgerechnet
heute vorstellte
ein zufall sagt er morgen nimmt der
untersuchungsausschuss zum bayer-kader
skandal seine arbeit auf zum ersten mal
haben zwei frauen den chemie nobelpreis
bekommen
fassungslos und hoch emotional seien sie
gewesen erzählen die amerikanerin
jennifer dauner und die in berlin
forschende französin emmanuelle
charpentier
sie haben die gen schere entwickelt eine
bahnbrechende entdeckung die helfen soll
krebs zu besiegen erbkrankheiten zu
heilen und pflanzen widerstandsfähiger
zu machen
thomas kommt ja so wenn ihr aus
stockholm
das püppchen gab es von einem filmteam
die echte große ehrung erhält sie im
dezember emmanuel chabrier forscht in
berlin nun gehört sie zu den größten
ich fühle mich äußerst die ehrt es ist
eine großartige entdeckung ich bin
glücklich dass ich dabei eine der
pionierinnen bin emanuele schöpfung ist
dorthin eingetaucht wohlleben entsteht
die entdeckung 2012 mit einer so
genannten gen schiere kann man den dna
strang an jeder beliebigen stelle
durchtrennen an der schnittstelle können
forscher dann gene ein- oder ausschalten
sie sogar austauschen ergebnis das
erbgut wird verändert ethisch kann das
fragwürdig seien
forscher manipulierten bereits die gene
von embryonen der mensch als labor
produkt zugleich offenbaren sich chancen
wir sehen dass die medizin dadurch große
fortschritte macht es wurden sogar
patienten schon geheilt und zwar
menschen die an bluterkrankungen lippen
getestet werden auch krebstherapien auch
die natur kann profitieren jennifer
dauer ebenfalls preisträgerin mit
entdeckerin der gen scheren sagt bald
kann man pflanzen züchten resistenter
gegen die umwelt man kann damit
menschheitsprobleme angehen auch dem
klimawandel etwas entgegensetzen
zwei große forscherinnen ein großer fund
man kann den code des lebens verändern
sie hoffen zum guten
und jetzt feiern wir ein richtiges
geburtstagskind vor 50 jahren wurde der
bayerische wald zum ersten deutschen
nationalpark es war ein besonderes
experiment mit dem obersten ziel die
natur sollte sich
jetzt reparieren ob dürre borkenkäfer
oder sturmschäden wie das funktioniert
hat zeigt conny hamann bald so weit das
auge blickt kilometer weit
seit 50 jahren heißt die philosophie
hier im nationalpark bayerischer wald
natur natur sein lassen ein wald in
denen der mensch nicht eingreift das
sichtbare resultat kommt bei den
besuchern an
das ist so bisschen mystisch sogar die
großen felsen die dunklen die kleine
murmelten welt jedes selber traum am 7
oktober 1970 wird deutschlands erster
nationalpark offiziell eröffnet mit
tiergehegen in denen auch bären luchse
und wölfe zu beobachten sind
doch ab den 1990 er jahren verbreitet
sich der borkenkäfer massiv heiße sommer
haben die vielen fichten im nationalpark
geschwächt
leichtes spiel also für den gefräßigen
käfer zehntausende fichten fallen ihm
zum opfer
doch die parkverwaltung greift ihrer
philosophie entsprechend nicht ein
ein wagnis das aufgegangen ist denn
totholz bildet wasserspeicher und den
nährboden für eine neue lebendige natur
in den einst betroffenen fichtenwäldern
sorgt für eine urwald gleiche wildnis in
den laubwäldern wenn man natürliche
prozesse in wäldern laufen lässt führt
das nicht zum absterben von wäldern
sondern zum absterben von bäumen der
wald konnte sich wieder regenerieren neu
bilden rund 1,4 millionen besucher
kommen heute jährlich in den
nationalpark gerade weil der mensch
nicht eingegriffen hat sie sich das
jetzt entwickelt und alles neu kommt
also es ist unglaublich schön natur
natur sein lassen ein experiment das
aufgegangen ist auch in zeiten des
klimawandels
die welt ist blöd aber man selber auch
das ist ein typischer herbert feuerstein
der kabarettist ist mit 83 jahren
gestorben
er packte auch ernste themen an
kultstatus bei seinen fans erreichte
feuerstein aber vor allem mit seinen
[Musik]
fast 20 jahre lang war chefredakteur des
satiremagazins mit bevor er sich in den
90er jahren an der seite von harald
schmidt wird kaum einem geld zu schade
war
du darfst du aber nicht vor hier ist
riesenslalom harald schmidt reagierte
heute so er sagte herbert feuerstein war
ein genie das hat er mir selbst gesagt
und ich habe es ihm bestätigt
zwei große großartig gehalten und jetzt
du grossrats er heute beim deutschen
fußball-bund der dfb soll jahrelang
steuern hinterzogen haben es geht dabei
um einnahmen aus der bandenwerbung bei
länderspielen größenordnung 4,7
millionen euro
rund 200 beamte waren im einsatz
durchsuchten am frühen morgen die dfb
zentrale in frankfurt am main und
privatwohnungen wie die des ehemaligen
vize präsidenten reinhard rauball sechs
frühere und aktuelle dfb funktionäre
stehen im fokus der ermittlungen
ihnen wird zur last gelegt einnahmen aus
der bandenwerbung von heim länderspielen
der fußball-nationalmannschaft aus den
jahren 2014 und 15 bewusst unrichtig als
einnahmen aus der vermögensverwaltung
erklärt zu haben
damit der dfb insoweit einer besteuerung
in höhe von etwa 4,7 millionen euro
entging der dfb hat die vermarktung der
bandenwerbung damals an die schweizer
firma infront verpachtet diese hätte
damit eigentlich frei entscheiden dürfen
wer den zuschlag bekommt und wer nicht
das problem dass nun steuerrechtlich
relevant wird der dfb soll trotzdem
einfluss auf die vergabe genommen haben
fritz keller erst seit gut einem jahr
der boss beim dfb wird schon wieder
eingeholt von der undurchsichtigen
vergangenheit des verbandes werden alles
an umfänglich unterstützen
ich bin angetreten für volle transparenz
und ich bin für aufklärung
einfach nur saubere zukunft für den
fußball
eine herkulesaufgabe für ihn und den
schwer angeschlagenen dfb ja frage dazu
an markus harm in frankfurt wieder mal
ist der dfb wegen altlasten aus der
vergangenheit ins visier der ermittler
geraten
das bedeutet das jetzt für den
weltgrößten nationalen sportverband die
glaubwürdigkeit des verbandes ist einmal
mehr sehr infrage gestellt es geht um
wissentlichen schweren steuerbetrug im
zeitraum 2014 2015 und die chefs damals
sollen das bewusst also diese
steuerhinterziehung bewusst in kauf
genommen haben beim dfb für die
steuererklärung zuständig sind präsident
general sekretär und schatzmeister im
fokus der razzien wohl auch deshalb
heute reinhard grindel damals
schatzmeister und die beiden
vizepräsidenten rainer koch und reinhard
rauball präsident damals wolfgang
niersbach der sagte heute bei ihnen gab
es keine durchsuchungen
mir liegt ein interner
untersuchungsbericht der dfb verträge
mit infront vor
darin heißt es es werden sachlich
unrichtige entscheidungen getroffen zur
bandenwerbung also eigene fehler
zugegeben das heißt gewohnt bewusster
steuerbetrug beim dfb das wäre ein
erneut der skandal
danke markus harm nach frankfurt nicht
zu herta nicht zurück zu den bayern
mario götze zuletzt beim bvb unter
vertrag und dann vereinslos geht zur psv
eindhoven in die niederlande
der 28 jährige fußballer erhält dort
einen zweijahresvertrag
laura siegemund ist bei den french open
im viertelfinale ausgeschieden ihrer
gegnerin eine nummer zu groß für sie
petra kvitova die zweimalige wimbledon
siegerin ließ der 32 jährigen aus
metzingen keine chance am ende eine
klare zweisatz-niederlage
sie wehrt sich laura siegemund mit
stopps und los so gut sie kann
allerdings gegen eine übermächtige
gegnerin
denn petra kvitova lässt von anfang an
keine zweifel an ihrer technischen
überlegenheit sie bestimmt die
ballwechsel und gewinnt satz eins mit 6
zu 3
auch im weiteren verlauf zitiert die
tschechien das spiel und hat nach 80
minuten ihren zweiten matchball
2623 das ergebnis für kvitova gegen eine
heute chancenlose laura siegemund da
habe ich wirklich jetzt maximale
wahrscheinlich ausgeholt und da muss man
dann auch zufrieden sein
nach der heutigen leistung wird b2
kvitova wohl fortan als turnier favorit
gelten
das war mir ganz schnell noch die
lottozahlen sie lauten 5 815 37 38 44
und die superzahl 0 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 5 157 verregnet im norden
deutlich freundlicher im süden so
präsentiert sich das herbstwetter morgen
die details hat gleich katja hornuf um
für den v10 meldet sich bettina
schausten mit dem heute journal
wir melden uns morgen wieder und
wünschen ihnen jetzt noch einen
unbeschwerten und schönen abend auf
wiedersehen